good morning John you and I we were
lucky enough to be raised in a country
where we got free education for 12 years
just didn't have to pay for you of
course did pay for some of it cuz you
had to go to a fancy boarding school
though I guess that turned out okay with
the book you wrote because of that and
all that level of free education is
pretty remarkable it's pretty cool thing
uh we don't think about it but you know
I learned a lot of good stuff learn how
to read how to do algebra play tectonics
what a mole is how to play marimba speak
some Spanish it's a nice gift that
society gave to me and I didn't hate
every minute of it but that did not stop
me from complaining about it constantly
of course since I was not the brightest
glow stick in the bag the things that I
was complaining about we're kind of
terrible the American education system
does have some problems and I want to
talk about two of the kind of
interrelated ones right now first for me
here's what education is it's building a
toolkit with which to solve problems and
and applying that toolkit in the solving
of problems you gotta have the necessary
tools and the scales to use them and
that involves knowing lots of discrete
pieces of information but it is much
more than that like we don't learn the
alphabet because it's good to know some
completely arbitrary letters in an order
we learn it because it helps us learn
how to read and write and reading and
writing solves the problem of the
impermanence of spoken words we can
write things down and then they'll last
much longer than if we just say them
which is they last this long and then
it's gone everything taught in schools
should be designed to increase our
collective problem solving toolkit and
all the things that are taught do that
u.s. history does that and long-division
dust and some of the problems are solved
just by having a more informed populace
like having people who all know the same
things and can agree on some basic stuff
like it would be really great I think it
would solve a lot of problems if we had
a Gender Studies course that was
required in high school but what I
remember if a lot of shoving stacks into
my short-term memory so that I could do
well on a test and then forgetting them
immediately and that did not make my
dual kit more robust the only thing that
really taught me was how to do well on
tests which I eventually got pretty good
at that's my first problem second the
toolkit that we develop in school and
out of school is the thing that we will
use for the rest of our lives to solve
problems personally and professionally
and professionally solving problems is
what you call a job but if everyone gets
the same toolkit in school then we have
a glut we have an oversupply of people
with that toolkit and when supply
outstrips demand
well I learned all about that in my
economics class that I had to wait until
college to take I worry about there not
being a broad enough diversity of
toolkit this is why at crash course
which is our educational YouTube channel
youtube.com slash car course we're
starting to look at the topics that are
a little bit more off the beaten path
we've just started anatomy and
physiology two weeks ago there's two
episodes of that up now that's basically
the study of your body how it works why
it works and when it breaks what happens
we also just yesterday launched crash
course astronomy hosted by Phil Plait
who was an astronomer and science
communicator that I can't believe I get
to work with so youtube.com slash crash
course you can learn about your body and
your solar system speaking of things
that I cannot believe and you may have
been waiting for this President Obama
who just announced that he's going to
try and make two years of Community
College free for all students thus
broadening the toolkit of Americans
I'm thumbs up on that one it's gonna
have a little conversation with me in
which we are going to hopefully talk
about some issues that matter to people
of America you may not be people of
America but if you are then please leave
things that you would like me to talk
about or thoughts that you have in the
comments or on various social media you
can use the hashtag YouTube asks Obama
that this one right there there it is it
will be live-streamed you can watch it
on the White House's YouTube channel and
January 22nd that's Thursday I promise
how well buek huh just talking about
freaks me out leave your questions that
will help me I appreciate that
I put an American flag back behind me
for the occasion and I'm wearing red red
and red and blue so look at me I'm
totally throwing it up alright John I'll
see you on Tuesday